hallo leute wissen wieder in berlin und
bei uns ist heute susanne ihr erinnert
euch vor kurz zu wahren wie in norwegen
dort haben die susanne bewusst eine
deutschlehrerin sitz und zu gast in
berlin
und was fragen wir heute die menschen in
berlin wir fragen heute die menschen in
berlin
was magst du an deinem beruf und susanne
wird das heute zusammen mit jana die
menschen jetzt auf der straße fragen ob
wir zusammen gut freue ich mich in
berlin
was mögen sie an ihrem beruf als
abwechslungsreich und bunt was machen
sie denn was meinen sie denn sie sind
einmal richtig ja ich habe meinen beruf
weil er sehr flexibel ist und weil was
mögt ihr an eurem beruf aber ich bin
opfer sängerin also ich freue mich so
eine künstlerin zu sein ein
das ist eigentlich am besten ist musiker
zu werden
ich bin gesangspädagogin diesen großen
rentner aber wir waren ziemlich aktiv in
unserem beruf wir wollen im außenhandel
was genau chemie export import war meine
profession aber jetzt schon jetzt einige
jahre her
sie sind jetzt seit fünf jahren schon im
rentenalter was ist das was dich
wirklich glücklich macht mit dem beruf
mit den menschen zusammen zu arbeiten
lauf zu sein schwan ich mag an meinem
beruf dass es zugleich mein hobby und
meine leidenschaft ist finde ich musiker
wasserstände arbeitet und was machst du
in deinen berufsalter aber ich mag die
redaktion halle in der die redaktionelle
tätigkeit kreativsein einfach nur ideen
dieser vor nur im kopf bilder umwandeln
und geschichten erzählen was bist du vom
beruf produzentin im animationsfilm
bereich ist das allerliebste was du
magst an diesem beruf also auf der bühne
zu sein und so also ich habe gerade
seine oper gemacht in mülheim seine nähe
von ihr erinnern also im süden
ich komme aus den usa und deswegen ist
es wirklich eine andere kultur zu
erfahren
hier in eine andere in einem anderen
land zu singen und was macht ihr an
deinen beruf am rechten spaß an meinem
beruf
internationales flair
ich habe sehr viele internationale
kollegen und den richtigen mix aus
herausforderungen und
relaxtes arbeiten und verraten auch was
für arbeit
ich bin im marketing ich habe als
marketing consulting sie am schönsten an
ihm bekommen fans genießen sie an ihrem
beruf
das viele geld das müssten sie dafür tun
ich liebe seine ärzte immer tolle
erfahrungen hier nicht der einzige
wirksame beliebt bei den meisten leuten
ärztliche technik sie ist richtig besser
geworden
natürlich davor stellt ist nicht zu
stoppen
ich mag das daran dass hier sehr viele
verschiedene menschen kommen aus
verschiedenen ländern ein hostel und man
dadurch ein bisschen abwechslung kriegt
obwohl man die ganze zeit monotoner
arbeit macht ein bisschen abwechseln
durch die leute umgang und der kontakt
menschen auf jeden fall bis nach und
kann die tories oder sony manchmal zu
erzählen haben wenn ihr auf
irgendwelchen anderen ländern kommen und
was für witzige verfehlen
an meinem beruf ich habe zwei berufe ich
bin dolmetscherin und beim gericht und
ich bin theaterpädagogin und was liebe
ich über alles theater durch die ganze
welt wird lernen
die unterschiedlichen menschen und das
geld trinkl großartig eine großartige
erfindung
ich studiere gerade produktdesign
momentan mag ich sehr
die unterschiedlichen bereichen wie man
forschen kann oder gehen kann weil wir
doch mal produktdesign muss aber einfach
das lehramtsstudium und die kreativität
weit ist alles sehr frei für die bbl mit
spezialisierung auf marketing und
marketing finde ich besonders
interessant dass man das kundenverhalten
untersuchen kann
und verstehen kann und was ist deine
lieblings oper
ich habe neulich die fledermaus von
johann strauß machten sie ihren beruf ja
ich mache mein beruf wir mochten berufs
ja was machen sie am liebsten an ihrem
beruf
dass man auch viel reisen konnte hat man
die welt kennengelernt
das war auch was sehr sehr schönes bei
welchen beruf stets zu an was fühlst zu
werden
ich glaube remp manager
was ist das da verbrachte zu quasi ganze
luftfracht an flughäfen
wie kommst du zu der idee das zu
studieren oder zu kurze frage bitte was
genießen sie an ihrem beruf
die zigarre das sehen wir es uns so gar
nicht mein beruf war die word privaten
gehandelt was denken sie an ihrem
rentner sein dass ich gezeigt habe
während vorsitzender rudi ziegler zu
bauen
die leuten zuzugucken echten rentner was
genießen sie an ihrem renn vorsah hat zb
der sich immer noch in die schule die
und kinder einander welt beibringen was
bringen sie den kinderball häkeln
stricken nähen welchen beruf
die kleinen zusammen mit der
künstlerischen leuten als eine
technikern die technisch affinen werden
und irgendwann auch und wirklich vom
charakter her
das war das beste an ihrem beruf
das beste an meinem beruf war an meine
kollegen früher später nicht mehr
man weiß nie was kommt es könnte der tod
langweilige seinen denn plötzlich
richtig los und außerdem ich arbeite mit
kollegen die kommen aus der ganzen welt
und ich finde das interessant
ich hab noch den zahnarzt in polen
erlebt vor 30 jahren wo er mit so einer
langsam maschine mir hier vorne mit dem
quatsch bewerbungsfoto noch nie gesehen
und aber es war halt vor so die schöne
verbindung und ich war früher in
frankfurt und in frankfurt durch eine
internationale gruppe und sie haben
nathan den weisen gespielt und dann
haben wir gespielt den festspielen in
mauritius und dann haben wir das spiel
in litauen und auch in tunesien weil da
bin ich auch geboren aber als vom sind
schon lange her ist es eine lange
geschichte und da du dich dazu
entschlossen hat auch erzieher zu werden
was interessiert dich da am meisten
kinder und die zukunft
gute erziehung ordentliche werte gesunde
menschen das domainfest an kindern
erzählen was ich will von denen lernen
und diese von mir lernen können und wie
ist sich vor dem publikum zu spielen
fußball und wenn das keinen spaß macht
dann ist es nicht das richtige beruf
also am besten wenn du wenn du dich
freust auf der bühne zu sein und kein
staat wieder zurück zu gerne was war
denn der beruf sind getrocknet da war ja
sehr viel spannendes also postbote ist
sehr interessant da laufe ich viel da
kann ich viele leute treffen bisschen
hektisch vielleicht opernsängerin
wer auf und wer wäre haben glücklich mit
seinen ruf was ich glaube der zahn hat
er wollte so richtig los hämmern mit
seinem presslufthammer okay halt wenn
ihr noch übungen zu machen zu unserem
vokabeln heute dann werdet doch
unbedingt zeit schon bei uns das könnte
hier machen und wenn ihr unbedingt
easyjet abonnieren wollt das macht doch
bitte hier
und startet nächste woche wieder ein
danke dass sie hier was uns in berlin
war mir eine freude ich komme gerne
wieder miss germany
das werdet unbedingt patches und
abonniert